well the new year is coming up uh it's a
time for New Year's resolutions I
suppose
not big on New Year's resolutions
because New Year's resolutions they
don't exist for the new year let's be
let's be real about it they exist for
all the months leading up to
the new year uh as a as a as a you know
an excuse for you to not make changes
right away the New Year becomes sort of
a receptacle for all of the commitments
that you don't want to make right away
because if you're serious about making a
change you're just going to start doing
it no matter what it is like if you say
I want to start dieting in the New Year
if you're actually going to die in the
new year you would just start right away
if you're serious about it you just that
moment start doing whatever it is as
Nike one of the most insightful
corporate mottos of all time just do it
this video is not sponsored by Nike so
that's why I feel about New Year's
resolutions but they feel differently
over on Tick Tock and over on Tick Tock
there are a bunch of people posting
their New Year's resolutions so we're
going to go through and watch those and
make fun of them New Year's Eve is
coming up and I just want to say don't
kiss no man it's New Year's Eve not New
Year's Stephen turn lesbian this is the
time that's actually kind of funny New
Year's Eve not New Year's Steve I I it
doesn't make any sense obviously but
making sense is not the bar that I'm
gonna set for a tick tock video because
it's not fair to them I'm disappointed
in the horrible homophobia in this video
because I've been reliably informed by
LGBT activists that nobody can choose
their sexuality so you can't turn
lesbian it's not it's it that's far
right propaganda actually it's very
dangerous you cannot change your
sexuality unless of course you're let's
say a heterosexual man who turns into a
woman and is then but is still attracted
to women in which case you that's really
the only way to turn into a lesbian I
guess you have to be a man first and
that's how you can turn into a lesbian
so you can't change your sexuality but
you can change your gender which in
turns in turn changes your sexuality
that's what we're told don't expect any
New Year's resolutions from me I intend
on staying the same snarky sarcastic
foul mouth you've all come to love
nobody does love you that's why you're
like this I mean this is the ultimate
female cope is what you just saw there
nobody likes you nobody wants to be
around you you're lonely and alone
and so you decide to embrace that as
your personality I'm a snarky [ __ ] up
this is default like you dye your hair
purple and just decide to to play it off
like like you meant to be this
incredibly off-putting and unpleasant so
it's kind of it's kind of the uh chicken
or egg sort of uh philosophical
conundrum in some ways I suppose did you
start off being this way and then nobody
liked you and so then you decide I think
that's really what it is that's what
that's what all purple hair is by the
way it is an attempt to turn
unpleasantness into a personality
anytime you see someone with purple hair
that's what they're doing that's what
the game is oh this is a good question
here are my 2023 resolutions comment
your resolutions the ones that you're
comfortable sharing in the comments
section
first I definitely want to get back to
parts of me
pre-panny you know 2020 happened a lot
happened all of our lives have been
significantly changed because of it
um but you know there were parts of my
life pre-panny I just want to kind of
recapture the essence of my life back
then um what am I talking about okay I
gotta cut it off right there I can't
even watch this anymore did she just
call the pandemic a panty and well I'm
is that am I am I reading that correctly
pre-panny is what we're calling the
pandemic now the pandemic was a panty so
we have a cutesy nickname for a pandemic
now something tells me that this is new
I don't think they did that like in the
in the black plague I didn't call it the
black it's the black panty it's
two-thirds of Europe has died in the
panty here's a New Year's resolution
it's not that hard to use an entire word
and I know pandemic you know that's
that's a multi syllabic word and
especially in the internet age people
find that very daunting but it's
actually doesn't take that much more
time so how much time does it take to
say the word panty versus pandemic it's
like an extra millisecond you're tacking
on and in the process you don't have to
sacrifice your dignity and sound like a
sound like a clown so that's I think I
think it's worth the commitment so I
don't even know what her New Year's
resolution is because we just skipped
over it we'll uh we'll keep going y'all
better not be doing any New Year's
resolutions in January European Society
got you thinking that you can make New
Year's resolutions in the middle of
winter they got you thinking that you
should start new things when Nature is
still hibernating this is not the time
to manifest new things and that's why
most of y'all will not succeed in your
New Year's resolutions mimic nature this
is a time to drop your leaves shed old
things hibernate reflect keep your ass
inside Journal meditate and keep
dropping those old habits that no longer
suit you and when spring comes around
and nature starts waking up then you
manifest something and watch how
everything will come to fruition so
follow me for more tips if you want to
tap back into nature what if I have a
job though that's the one problem just
stay inside all winter yeah I mean if
you're if you're living in your parents
house then then I suppose you could do
it speaking of like of turning things
into personalities and just going with
it so you know you get the unpleasant
women put the purple hair on it's like
well this is my personality now and then
there's this too someone who's just a
loser doesn't have a job and is living
at their parents house and then decides
to wear a bunch of Jewelry in a turban
or whatever that is and then say I'm I'm
enlightened I'm gonna I'm gonna re
repackage myself as enlightened and
above it all no it's just you don't have
a job that's what it is
although I do kind of like this idea I
mean there's something to it I'm going
to start using this with my with my wife
when she tells me like oh we need to
clean out the garage this weekend I can
say no sorry it's winter I don't
manifest new things in the winter okay I
can't manifest a new a a clean garage
right now get back to me in the
springtime nature is hibernating right
now no nature is not like there's still
nature you do understand that right
it's it's that's nature itself doesn't
go away nature just you walk outside and
that's and it's all nature have we even
heard one real resolution
so I've decided for 2023
I'm just gonna keep getting hotter and
weirder that's my resolution too I have
to say but I will say in your case the
makeup seems to be so you want to get
hotter and weirder the makeup seems to
be helping with the weirder resolution
but it's not doing much for the hotter
resolution but this is just me
oh
okay you know what I just wanted
something easy like eat my vegetables
this on why yeah she's actually right yo
love yourself is uh that's a difficult
resolution
to manifest as the other guy would say
it's actually a horrible resolution it's
basically impossible like you can't
decide that my New Year's resolution is
I'm going to love myself more you can
sit around all day
thinking about yourself and thinking
about how you feel about yourself and it
just becomes this self-cannibalizing
cycle where you're circling around the
drain and you could you could do that
but you're not going to be able to
conjure this love for yourself that
you're trying to which is why it would
be a really bad way to go into the new
year loving yourself I'm not saying that
you shouldn't love yourself We Are All
Made in the image of God
and so we are God's creation
and so for that reason we should love
ourselves we should even we should
accept ourselves that's true think of it
more of as a of a byproduct of a healthy
life you're living a healthy life you
will also love yourself but not in this
self-obsessive way it's more like you're
just you're fulfilling your
responsibilities you're doing your duty
your your uh living a healthy life and
then one day you look back and you
realize oh I feel good about myself I
love myself it's a byproduct it's just
something that it's something that comes
along with the territory of doing the
things that you're supposed to do so
focus on those things rather than
because what people do these days is
they do it the other way around they sit
around thinking well I need I need to
feel better before I can do anything
before I can do anything constructive
and have a healthy life I need to feel
better about myself first and then once
I feel better about myself then I can
start doing all of the the healthy
things but there's no reason for you to
feel better about yourself because
you're not doing anything that's that
will kind that will that will create
those feelings you see that's that
that's the problem hi this is for my
baby friend friends but if you're not a
gay B you're more than welcome to say
we're inclusive here I'm sitting here in
my closet thinking of you and knowing
that some of you might be setting a
resolution to come out this year would
it make it easier if you had someone to
practice with I'm happy to be your
practice person I'll go live at two
o'clock Central Time on New Year's Day
if you want to practice coming out to me
I'm here and I welcome you if you want
to ask me anything else you can do that
too see you on New Year's
I don't know exactly what's going on
here this is an old woman in a closet
talking to her gabies and offering to
let them practice coming out to her
this is a
imagine this is your grandmother where's
Grandma she's in the closet shooting
another Tick Tock video
I guess this is the new version of a guy
in a van offering free candy this is the
the
some of the least subtle grooming I've
ever seen you know what as far as coming
out as your New Year's resolution goes
I've got a different idea very similar
to what we said before how about this
here's here's a good resolution
especially for people on tick tock
stop talking about your sexuality
stop obsessing over it stop making it
your whole Essence and personality try
to formulate some kind of existence
outside of that you know what actually
stop thinking about yourself in general
to the extent that you can
and go out and live your life
Tamp down the narcissism that will give
you less content for tick tock videos
but it will lead
to an actually happy
Happy New Year
[Music]
[Applause]